[Music]
please be upstanding members to receive
the chairman the Chairman's chaplain and
the managing director please remain
standing for prayers which will be given
by Reverend Tracy Marlowe pray father
thank you for every seat that has been
filled to you today for each mind and
heart that feels the presence of this
room would thank you
only you truly know what we're setting
out to accomplish today and in the
months ahead we have an idea of vision
hints and daily instructions we have
talents abilities and time to work
however only you can see in perfect
detail the end of every beginning every
project every season every life nothing
is ever in vain for either mistakes and
missteps are used for good your
righteousness transcends all our efforts
and understanding forgive us our pride
the pride that pops us up and deprived
at threatens to unqualified us
strengthen our confidence in who you
have made us to be set us free from
comparison in order to work together
efficiently bless this meeting today and
all those present as well as the lives
of those we will encounter afternoon
ready us to make every moment count in
Jesus name Amen
please be seated numbers good evening
members and welcome thank you it is on
can you hear me can everybody hear me
good evening members and officers for
this the full council meeting on the
16th of july 2019
I take agenda item 1 apologies for
absence we have received apologies in
the office from counters Hudson IO new
and mrs. Christine Mason are there any
others at all
no thank you agenda item 2 the minutes
of the annual meeting held on the 14th
of May 2019 do members approve the
minutes as a correct record of the
meeting Thank You members I shall sign
them later agenda item 3 declarations of
interest do members have any interests
to declare No thank you very much ladies
offer advice that I am I do sit on and
wait to be advised of the exact wording
but I sit on I don't sit on but I don't
represent this council on it but I don't
sit on the coastal community team for
the middle crouch Thank You aloneness no
counselor mr. counselor mrs. hoi
Thank You agenda item four announcements
from the Chairman leader of head of paid
service there are none from the managing
director or leader but one thing I would
like to let members know is the my two
charities that I've chosen for my year
they are the outsider Society and the
Royal National Lifeboat Institute agenda
item five public questions and member
questions on notice of which there are
none agenda item six business from last
council there there is none agenda item
seven to note the minutes of executive
and community committee meetings held
between the period 20th of April 2019
and a 5th of july 2019 are those minutes
meetings noted members thank you very
much agenda item 8 report from the
executive and committees to Council for
two items I would take item 8 1 the
report of the review committee review of
the Constitution councillor Burton
chairman of the review committee we'll
introduce this report councillor Burton
Thank You chairman this report members
will be aware was deferred presented
some minor adjustments have been made to
it
those have subsequently been reviewed
again by pork hours there's also an
additional appendix which has been
edited by Angela really just for
administrative purposes it's theirs
there's no dramatic changes it's all to
be noted other than that that's the
final piece of that overall project
Thank You councillor Burton any
questions at all net members no do you
do members then approve the
recommendation on page 8 1 1 of the
report agreed thank you
and
can also members confirm that the
recommendations on the addendum is
agreed as well is that agreed thank you
I shall now take item eight to the
report of a review committee treasury
management annual review 2018 19 and
again this will be introduced by
councillor Burton Thank You chairman
firstly members please note that there
is an error containment in the report
which is also shown on the agenda
actually this evening and that being
that it refers to the 2017-18 review
period which of course is incorrect
should show the 2018-19
period as members will see in addition
to the report which is mostly
self-explanatory appendix B has also now
been included following the request from
a member of review committee for
clarification on the information in the
graph and paragraph or three of the
original report this information is now
being provided and I'd like to think no
you me for providing this promptly and
prior to this meeting the recommendation
is for members to note the contents of
the treasury management annual review
for the period 2018 to 19 with the
inclusion of appendix B my trustees will
be accepted Thank You councillor Burton
any questions members no we have one
recommendation on page 8 to 1 of the
report that the contents of the treasury
management annual review be noted do
members note the review thank you agenda
item 9 report on urgent decisions
there is one reporter of wanded urgent
decision is set out on page 9.1 do you
note the report thank you agenda item 10
report of the leader of the work of the
Executive Council of Steptoe will now
report to the council on the work of the
executive since the last council meeting
councillor Steptoe yes thank chairman
this is the first ordinary meeting my
first report has leader to the council
first of all during meeting of the
2019-20 you sit for a year and I would
like to welcome all members since the
meeting on the 30th of April of the
executive was has met twice during which
consider consideration is included
awarding a new five-year contract to
capita business services for one
revenues and Benz cloud service and
comes in the provision of academies
software which is required to carry out
the council's core revs and Benes
services with immediate start date award
a new five-year contract for Oxford
District Council's banking services to
Lloyds banks as from the 1st of August
2019 the Frisia provision out turn
position against the 2018-19
a revenue budget spending of the
allocated 2019-20
capital budget for play space
improvement delegated authority the
assistant director of place and
environment to award contracts for the
delivery place spaces Improvement
Program to seek and to seek and secure
appropriate match funding to assist in
the delivery of the play spaces
improvement programme designating the
Beagle event as a silver project
approved the drawdown of 25,000 pound
from earmark reserves provide a working
capital budget agreeing that the draft
event management plan and associated
equity equality impact assessment be
reported to the executive before
submission to the Safety Advisory Group
proves the leisure and cultural strategy
2019 to 24 noting the latest version of
the projects program management office
PM dashboard to the executive other
matters that my exist of colleagues and
I have dealt with include a proven the
environmental health service plan for
2019-20 signing a statement of common
ground with Baz Luhrmann's Borough
Council in relation to the Basile and
Bharat local plan 2014 234 finally
Chairman I would like to take this
opportunity to refer for motion on
notice that raised was raised at full
council 11th of December of 2018 in
which we pledged to work alongside Essex
County Council and local communities in
both shaping and delivering future
library provision throughout the
district and so brought supporting the
retention of light of a labral service
in all of the current five existing
areas in the district I'm delighted that
following public consultation on the
future of the library service the County
Council announced on the 9th of July
that no libraries will close over the
next five years and I look forward to
working with members Essex County
Council Eaton exploring of bringing our
library service into the 21st service
21st century for the benefit of air
ism's as always chairman are we happy to
take any questions from members in
respect to the work of the executive and
I'm sure my executive colleagues will be
happy to contribute we're broke
Thank You councillor Steptoe councillor
Adam mr. Hawaii
Thank You chairman thank you for their
care so step two is just a couple of
points I'd like to mention and then just
a question towards the end is
interesting about the place-based
improvements I think most of most
opposition councillors anyway I think
have already met with them mr. cotton
around this on how I have that all our
group s as well one of the concerns I
did raise with mr. hunter not just
under-- if you connect if you would
agree with this is that a lot of the
solutions to play space equipment often
comes down to skate park my shoe at the
skate park is that off it's often very
gender biased halls young men shall we
say I very rarely see young women on
there or girls on there so I did ask if
it's possible to maybe try to have a
look at the gender balance of play
equipment in the future I know that
there's one area which has got a cotton
of what is called a zip file that's
one's thank you very much yes sir
as if I would I think as much I know
young girls certainly write those I've
said money it's hurting my daughter you
see when she was a little bit younger so
that's one question if your if your
support that the idea around the gender
bias trying to avoid that if possible
I'm really delighted to see that the
Beagle project is moving on this is
something that I remember sitting - how
many years ago in a dining room in
Hopewell with former councillor John
Mason and Mr Dave when he was the chief
executive and we spoke about at the
Battle of Ashenden Essendon as I was
taught and the fact that the Beagle was
in the district and he was quite
enthralled by the idea of both of those
I thought she one didn't get off the
ground looks like the second one is so
thank you for that finally I just
quickly want to move on to the final
thing you said not to have to some
questions on this because I know it's
about questions I've wrecked the know
strategy on the the library and I would
call it well opaque is an understatement
I would say there's no information
supplied about the types of community
groups or organizations that have come
forward and there's no identification of
libraries which may be earmarked for
voluntary groups to run or organizations
and really it seems little difference
the first one so just troit on what
you've said here you you're talking
about working with members in Essex
County Council I don't know what how we
work with members will that include
opposition members particularly in those
areas where there are libraries such as
whole bridge for instance and also are
you able to confirm whether or not
you're aware of any community groups
that have come forward to run I was in
the district already and which libraries
they may have come forward offering to
run thank you
cancer sniped Oh would you like to reply
let me take the last question first with
regards to the libraries it is a county
matter and I think discussions with
County members should be in order but
I'm quite happy to work with all
councillors regardless of political
persuasion with regards to community
groups I can only at the moment speak
for my own library down in great white
green which comes into my County
Division and we have been talking to a
group down there which are quite keen to
actually look at taking that forward
that's what we now need to do as far as
we're concerned with the libraries is to
identify exactly where we're going
forward with regards to the beagle and
the Battle of ashen doom
there are things coming forward as far
as the battle is concerned not least of
all we've just been awarded a grant for
our tapestry I think the figure when I'm
looking at Angela very quickly
ten thousand ten thousand parents that
so there are projects coming forward for
that and speaking personally I've been
trying to find out why Ashington church
is a Minster and not an ordinary parish
church some research there to be done
I do apologize chairman I've forgotten
the first can you yes having watched
some television recently I just happened
to turn on a program and they were
talking about skateboard parks and there
is quite a large following of lady
skateboarders so I would hate to say
that they are purely just for me and I
think that would be very unwise for me
to suggest that um but yes I do take the
councillors point but perhaps some
pieces of play equipment might be a
little bit gender bias but I'm sure the
officers will take that into account
thank you - Thank You councillor Steptoe
cassity's did you indicate you wish to
speak thank you no other questions will
now take I Tony Levin emotions on notice
members we have one motion on notice
proposed by councillor mr. high and
seconded by accounts to Stanley Council
hi would you like to speak on your
motion of notice Thank You chairman I
should have asked this before he's a
long time since offered emotion do you
want me to read the motion asking for if
you want to take this trade and it's in
the papers but I'm happy to read it if
you want it already I should take the
advice from members but does do members
wish it to be read or are you happy to
take it from and from the papers
yeah take it as written anything thank
you
saves a bit of time as well probably I
won't take long over this I think
everyone in the chamber will be aware of
the issues over and all use the most
climate change I'm going to use any
extreme language direct the motion has
been worded in such a way that it is I
think fairly accessible to most people
this is a motion that has been broadly
used around many areas in the country
many councils have passed a motion very
similar to this
obviously tailored towards the area they
are the first one to pass a motion in
this form was Bristol and many have done
since of all political persuasions not
Green not Lib Dem not conservatives not
labor everybody and quite often
unanimously as well I feel that the the
motion is trying to move us in the right
direction it doesn't commit us to say we
will do is committing us to do their
best endeavours to move us towards
carbon neutrality by 2030 2030 is the is
the day other organizations you might
have seen earlier dates 2025 they will
admit that it's probably quite difficult
to move a council such as this to carbon
neutrality in that time scale so we're
going with 2030 the the intention would
be for the cast as a whole to move this
way so it's a holistic idea that
obviously at the moment if you look
further on we're talking maybe about an
electric vehicle for mechanical street
street screaming sweeping so but that's
an individual's decision taken by an
individual portfolio holder or officer
this will try and move to develop a
policy within the council to do that it
funds it properly
and it provides the ability for the
council to move forward on that basis
I'm not going to say it's been easy or
would be easy obviously there is
criticism from about some councils
passing a motion like this and they're
not really doing very much towards the
odd I again would not like the idea that
we just passed a motion and we think
we've done something really good it's
got to really mean something I have I
have to say although many opposition
meant most mockers opposition members
have signed this I didn't manage to get
in touch with all of them but most have
I did actually float this through to the
conservative group as well to see if
they would be happy and I have had a
meeting but I understand that it might
not be possible at this time to for them
to support this which I would find
rather sad if that's the case I'll leave
it there I think there's nothing for me
to say is quite self-evident if you look
in the press you look at the news you
can see the problems and you can see the
importance of us doing this thank you
Thank You councillor mr hoy can slim
sees McPherson Thank You chairman sorry
I didn't expect you come to me so
quickly
um I'm just picking up on some of the
things that councillor hoist just a
mentioned first of all I think in habló
I know I I'm correct that every person
in this chamber shares the same view for
us to become carbon neutral and that
should be a goal however councilor who I
mentioned this is broadly used I'm glad
you said that because when I had a look
at it I had a Google and every single
counts or has gone through this but
that's what it is it's a template most
of them have used exactly the same
template one of the ones about um
counsel who I mentioned our best
endeavors in it's not a promise it's a
way of working to get our best
endeavours we should have something in
front of us that's bespoke to Rochford
to our needs not a template we've lived
the way
without being recycling scheme and other
environmentally friendly' projects let's
lead the way here I would like to see a
bespoke model how are we going to do
that there we go
and I made another know about if it was
more bespoke you're going to get there
quicker because you will have smart
achievements so that's what I would say
about this I would like to see something
more bespoke to our needs here and what
should I think ooh counselor mrs.
McPherson there counselor mr. wooden
German thank you indeed I read the
motion with much interest and councillor
Hoyle is up already acknowledge that it
is a template and it is what really the
Local Government Association have been
suggesting council councils might adopt
and indeed the first part is a very
informative and sets out the
consequences of doing nothing based on
the facts to do nothing would not be
responsible however we have to
acknowledge that Rockford Council has
been taking action and will continue to
be responsible on this particular
subject but I think what we're all
saying is that more can be done with a
more structured considered and focused
approach best endeavors frankly isn't
good enough on a subject of this type
indeed prior to this motion the leader
has already given a public commitment in
his wish that Rockford Council should
become carbon neutral by 2030
so exactly as you said council ahoy
there is commitment I believe across the
the chamber however this motion in the
way it is written and I'm really
referring to the latter points is weak
on outcomes and how to achieve the goals
and again in fairness the council oh boy
he talked about best endeavors and
aspirations I believe more work needs to
be done to ensure there is a greater
commitment and ownership by us as a
council and as councillors to take
ownership of the way in which we take
this forward for these reasons whilst
for the avoidance of doubt I fully
support the concept of what it is trying
to achieve as it is currently written by
regret chairman that I cannot support
this motion at the present time Thank
You councillor Ft
it's also much lately castleroy when
he's trying to do this but again this
just seems to be going to the money's
going to outside bodies who made a
template and it just doesn't seem to be
bespoke - what for districts again I'd
like to see us make bespoke commitments
for this moving on and again I can't
support it away is in the moment so here
we go Thank You counsel board thank you
very much chairman I think the concept
is highly commendable and I think the
majority of members do support the
concept of that direction although my
biggest concern is is is on the fiscal
side to actually understand what the
price would be in regards to residents
because I think that needs to be looked
at very very seriously I think we have a
very green and present district we have
woods which are I would guess one of our
greatest assets in as much they do help
to maintain that carbon neutrality but I
think we need to look at this in greater
depth and I think quite rightly we do
need to have something that is more
bespoke to this district things that are
truly achievable rather than something
that is maybe from another place thank
you
thank you councillor eaves thank you
care I've listened to a lot of the
comments on what has actually been put
forward here and I think this is a
commendable report to actually put
forward to the council not only from the
counters point of view but to make a
statement to our public as to what our
intent is I think one of the things that
I think is a bit of a danger in what I'm
hearing so far is that it sounds to me
as though the conservative group or
there are members who will not be
agreeing
what we've gotta be careful of is the
message that it sings if we say we do
not agree with this now one of the
things that everyone has said is that
we're looking for a wire hey we're
looking for some substance and I suggest
that we make an amendment and the
amendment is along the lines of there we
will be looking to put a working party
together to see how we can achieve the
aims it seems as though that would
actually counteract a lot of the
questions that have been put to this
report tonight so if we could actually
make maybe making a minute on there too
to be forming a working party as a
result presenting this report thank you
thank you
councillor Wilkinson Thank You Jamie mmm
I actually agree with them what counsel
he was just said actually he's just
taken one of the points I was going to
make with respect to a lot of the
comments I've heard this evening and not
taking away the fact that clearly
everybody in the chamber does agree with
the concept to what we're talking about
here and with respect to reporting I've
heard a lot of criticism about it and a
lot of well we can't do it we can't do
that but nothing positive now we don't
know my phone in my hand is because I
don't know whether anybody else who's on
social media unfortunately like me has
seen watcher District Council's more
recent social media outpouring which was
about the electric charging vehicles and
it says environmentally-conscious
watcher District Council delighted to
introduce nine electric vehicle charging
points it goes on and all the hashtags
at the end it talks about hashtag
environments hashtag environment
friendly hashtag climate change hashtag
make the change which is really
interesting and I applaud whoever put
that out because I think that that sends
a really really positive strong message
but unfortunately what I don't hear is
us supporting that message and I can
completely stand by accounts the Hori
with this much
and I think it needs to be a doctor and
I think they'd suggest from the
amendment that's been put forward by
councilor Yves is a credible one it
doesn't need to be pushed to one side we
need to make a decision tonight about
what we are going to do because clearly
there is excuse me there is support for
this concept as it's been called so what
are we going to do about it and I think
the working party is the right way for
because we can't leave this chamber
without some decision I would suggest a
fixture sounds to Stanley I think each
other this this report that's been
caught by council avoid is a beginning a
very straightforward beginning whether
you call it a template a concept or
bespoke or whatever you like to call it
that's on your words this is a good bit
of work that has been done by Councillor
and he's put it to all of you and we all
want to do that now when we put in
electric charging points where do we get
the electricity from I know a nuclear
power station that puts out I've got a
carbon footprint or any pair station if
you like but we're not using solar
panels we're not using that Sun up there
that can give us a lot of energy so I've
put this to you is that if we are going
to go down this road we need to use
their energy that's free and it is free
it's going to be their admitted we might
have to use a certain energy during the
winter but we can use an awful lot of
energy during the summer and we have
roofs on these property and that can
give us a lot of energy so I think this
move by councillor Hoyt it is one we
need to look at and put together all of
us put together put that little bit of
effort in each one of us to get it down
and I got to second this motion thank
you
councillor Burton Thank You chairman
I've listened I've not spoken to any any
members at all about this motion my
first reaction when I read it was that
to me it appeared to be a very generic
template that's being used and it's been
said this evening that what will our
residents think if we don't accept this
motion actually I think our residents
will think we're putting them first
again if they were to know that we were
just accepting a generic template that
really applies to councillors such as us
in the City Council's I think they'd
probably be a bit insulted by that that
we weren't actually putting anything and
identifying exactly what we can do for
them and setting some realistic goals so
I think as it appears there's a lot of
enthusiasm for a motion of this nature
but this just isn't it I don't think
anybody is taken away from councillor
hoi the their appreciation for the work
he's put into putting this motion
forward this evening but I don't think
based on the fact that it is a generic
template I don't think we'd be doing our
residents any favors by accepting its
even Thank You councillor Burton does
anybody else wish to speak so I'm
counselor mrs. Macpherson Thank You
chairman just reflect some more
councillor Wilkinson said I don't think
anybody has downed this at all as I
started at the beginning everybody in
this chamber agrees with this that we've
got to do think about climate change
councillor Burton's just thumped it up
do we present to our residents a
template for everybody's done or do we
give them something better that's what I
put forward thank you no sir mr. Hawley
thank you I'm sorry just really come
backs on those comments that's okay
there's been a lot of use of the word
template yes them this is a motion which
sets out some guidelines of how this
council can act and in what direction
this council could move by looking at
the council in detail looking at the
error in detail and working out to a
bespoke plane for this council
it starts with a if you like a template
it's a template geared towards this
council it's not clear towards the City
Council is clear towards this council to
work out the the word needs such that it
will help us get to where we need to go
the from what I hear about what some
members of this council want is the work
to be done and then be provided with a
very detailed report on exactly what
should be done I don't believe that's
the right way I think this council
should work out how it should approach
the the problems of climate change in
climate breakdown I was quite pleased so
I hope I didn't miss here the council
steps out and correct me if I did me see
this but I'm sure I heard that
councillor stepped out of committee for
the council to be carbon neutral by 2030
which is if that was the case and I
wasn't miss hearing that's very pleasing
to hear obviously a motion like this
would help in that finally or two more
things I did give the opposition an
opportunity quite clearly I said the
motion had been put but I'm quite happy
to withdraw the motion if you feel that
it could be worded differently or better
I said there's only a couple of things
which I was quite keen about not
changing and that was the date of 2030
which sounds like everyone's happy with
that and the cost of two hundred
thousand pounds which I had put on the
draw down which may have been wrong made
me rise my best guesstimate of how much
it would need on the basis that
that I was told you that you weren't
taking up that offered to change it I
didn't I don't understand why you're now
saying that he shouldn't be a template
it should be more detailed I'm sorry
that's a bit confusing and finally I
just like to say that the price of the
price for residents for us not acting
now he's a is climate breakdown that is
the truth
and it might might be hard for some
people to understand but the time it
will break down councilor Steptoe may
not have a house to live in it may be
under water great Wakering is in very
great danger of that and this is what we
are trying to avoid or doing our best
endeavors
to avoid there's nothing wrong with work
use of the word endeavors there nothing
wrong with the best of our abilities if
we use the best of our abilities we can
achieve this there is a lot of ability
in this chamber Thank You Chancellor
Hawk why Thank You chairman um
[Music]
originally when I read this motion
I wasn't minded to support it there was
a couple of issues that I had but I
think across the whole chamber there
does seem to be a certainly a level of
support for something to be done we seem
to be quibbling about how we might get
round to coming up with a policy or a
proposal or way forward to do that so on
that basis I do support the the
amendment because I think that gives
a way forward to take this to allow
across the whole of the chamber the
ability for the talent within this
chamber to to come together to work on
something which is an important issue we
all have concerns for our environment
whether that's locally in our own
villages or towns in a broader sense
we've been ruptured and across the whole
country as well so I think that what
it's been put forward by council Reeves
is a it's a very good suggestion council
burden certainly just like look why Sir
I know you very well and that the motion
hasn't been the amendment hasn't yet
been port beam second demon slipper I
knew what you meant cast I think
sorry I would say that I'm on the basis
that the rest of the chamber would
support that amendment I would also
support it councillor burden thank Jim
just a quick message to members as well
that this is do or this subject is due
to come before review committee later
this year in part so it may be worth
bearing in mind councilor eaves do you
have a seconder for your a proposed
amendment Thank You counsel hook wait a
second did that amendment do you speak
councillor Wilson sorry okay my
apologies okay sorry chairman of the
sorry I'm a bit of a nerd sometimes that
I think has councilor eaves put forward
the motion yet
because he put it forward before our
motion was seconded to therefore he
couldn't he you cannot amend a motion
until he said just what it make sure
it's done properly that's all under the
impression has already been seconded the
I didn't feel like being caught that was
all council Eve can you formally put
forward your amendment please agrees to
put forward a working party cross party
a cross-party working party to explore
ways to achieve the aims of the body
okay okay okay I used to happy to second
there right we'll take a vote on that
amendment then please those in favor
those against
any abstentions that amendment has not
been passed thank you any more questions
members no then we'll take a vote on the
motion on notice it sir just one point
of her May just before you invite and I
just just a point I just wanted to make
with respect to catch them at first and
respect to the conservative group is
that I may have made I may be
misunderstood in the points I was trying
to make there is a reason why I'm saying
this and I'm not trying to downplay any
commitment from you at all to what this
to what you're trying to achieve okay
thank you councillor Wilkinson Wright
will now take a vote on the think of
councillors there'll be a recorded vote
councillor Burton counselor mrs. butcher
can't slicker now counselor mr. Carter
and canceler mrs. Carter counselor cut
more
councillor Dre against cancer FD
councillor eaves can still hook away
counselor mrs. hoi counselor mr. hoi
cancer Lucas girl counsel mrs lammle
answer mr. McPherson handsome Eric
cancer known answer Newport Chancellor
problem counselor mrs. Rowe
handsome mrs. Shaw answer mr. Shaw
that's the Smith that's the sparing can
system me how's this step 2
how's the ward
comes to the web
councillor Wilkinson answer Williams
house the Wilson
and can't Salutin
remembers the notice of motion has been
lost at nine for twenty-two against and
one abstention councillor Williams Thank
You chairman whilst I applaud the
motives of the previous but I have
concerns with the ability to deliver
this without further consultation
therefore I moved to propose that review
committee be asked to set up a
cross-party working group so as to
understand the implications and
recommend a policy to this council on
how it can reduce the carbon footprint
and become carbon neutral by 24 point
folder selection on notice promotional
notice chairman Issa I motion also
notice but is directly related to the
current debate on the floor but on the
point of audition this has been raised
during the the actual discussion of the
motion that the motion is now date so
therefore the nothing else could be
racist is a new motion no this is a
motion which must be on urgent business
I can't see that it qualifies for
anything other than it should be
emotional notice thank you no Chairman
he doesn't need to be emotional notice
okay you can carry on counselor Williams
thank you it's a condition also to
consider and understand the costs and to
investigate external funding sources I'm
so to consider how it helps with
encourage developers to design carbon
neutral through the process to recommend
a policy for this council to consider by
April 2020 and to regularly update the
portfolio holder for the amount through
the hopefully out of the environment on
its work the council also pulls up on a
majesty's government to explore
supporting domestic implementation of
sustainable development goals through
funded partnerships roles within local
authorities to encourage the parishes to
work with our DC to achieve carbon
neutrality
on a point of order chairman if this
motion is to be discussed by this
council and I understand the assistant
director has said it can be we have just
heard of this motion he is quite lengthy
with the chairman be willing to suspend
Standing Orders and to distribute the
motion to us so that we can actually
understand what we are talking about
thank you
two members agree to adjourn the meeting
for ten minutes no okay okay yes can we
have a seconder please for that motion
thank you
those in favor please the motion please
indicate perhaps I can assist here
I think councillor hi brought forward a
request for a vote on whether we should
have an adjournment and that is what we
are voting on not the amendment has but
has been proposed please correct me if
I'm wrong on that point okay members it
is a vote with regard to the adjournment
those in favor of a 10-minute
adjournment German please indicate those
against that has been lost
Thank You councillor eaves this is
something that has been brought to the
chamber which obviously is protected and
everyone in the administration has
obviously had a chance to take their
season this has been a complete surprise
to us
this is shambolic it's disgusting yeah
councillor Wilkinson chairman thank you
the points I was going to say actually
before when I sort of realized Pat
sessions who stood up was 290 should
acknowledge what to counsel my first
assemblies were also to say that we need
to take away from here I did say this
when I start ups to look before we must
take away from here something positive
not just turn down a motion because we
need to support what the council's
trying to achieve I said that before we
voted on counts the house motion I said
that before we voted on councillor
Reeves amendment clearly with councillor
Williams having that in his hand which
has typed out it's cleared that the
whole of the conservative group was
pleaded
in this you knew how you were going to
vote and this has not allowed a fair and
open debate of this important subject
this evening thank you Jim the canal
thank you chair I'm just looking for
clarity really is it as a newish member
I don't mind playing naivety card and
the the motion on notice is in front of
us this this feels like this was
defeated and this is now a new motion
that a lot of us haven't had access to
new material for is that the chairs
interpretation of the events right now
thank you
anybody else wish to speak on this item
councillor Williams can I ask you to
read the motion yet again please thank
you chairman I moved to propose that
review committee be asked to set up a
cross-party working group so as to
understand the implications and
recommend a policy to this council on
how it can reduce the carbon footprint
and become carbon neutral by 2030 at the
latest to consider and understand the
cost and to investigate external funding
sources to consider how this council can
encourage developers to design carbon
neutral homes and commercial premises
through the planning process to
recommend a policy for this council to
be to consider by April 2020 and to
regularly update the portfolio holder
for the environment on its word this
council also calls upon Her Majesty's
Government to explore supporting
domestic implementation of sustainable
development goals through funding
partnerships roles within local
authorities to encourage the parishes to
work with RDC to achieve carbon
neutrality
I think of chairman and I stand to
second the motion and while I'm on my
feet I will say a few words if I may as
always already been said I think
everybody in this room acknowledges the
fact that we do need to do something but
we do need something that needs to be
spoke to Rockford District Council and
not just a generic motion that has been
taken off the peg throughout the rest of
the country this came up at a lot of
discussion at the LGI conference and
many things we need to look and find it
understand what we need to do
specifically for our council it can be
for a simple thing for example I hope I
hate to single a Jarell sitting there
using a plastic one use borrow now there
are wooden pins available we should be
looking at perhaps things like that
we've already spoken about the
possibility of having electric vehicles
as it's all really being mentioned where
are we going to source that electric
supply from because no point in having
electric vehicle if you're then powering
it from a coal-fired power station or a
gasifier pesto's so there's lots to look
at we also need to consider what our
carbon footprint is and how we can
offset because you can't be totally
carbon neutral but you need to look at
coltan or sit there is a report coming
before the Investment Board in tomorrow
which reports that over the last couple
of years or so we've replies did
something like 32,000 trees we've got
considerable number of trees in hockey
woods I'd hate to send somebody out to
actually have to count them but I think
we need to look at we've got large
woodlands along the a12 7 we've got
large woodlands in Raley that's needs to
all to be taken into account
and as counsel Burton's already
mentioned when I attended the review
committee I did ask the review committee
to consider this is a topic and to take
it forward and I feel that that is the
right place that cross-party working
group can be set up and in a report back
with an all encompassing strategy that
this council can actually work to and
understand are there for second emotions
Thank You councillor styptic Anil Thank
You chair I'm slow mildly confused so I
will make my my first point as a
question and I'm wait before I continue
and is this a new motion we are being
asked to consider it is yes okay is that
normal practice that a new motion would
come up in the chamber and be discussed
in the chamber am i - yes yes directly
related to the original notice or motion
as long it says it related to the
original thing like that clarity what
what we've just heard proposed sounded
very similar to what counsel Eve's had
already asked for when we voted against
I guess I'll be looking for for clarity
on how it is different to what we've
already rejected thank you - Stanley
Thank You chairman it's been pointed out
that yeah we probably have partied
32,000 trees but my I point out that
grass is the most efficient carbon
holder than before trees unless you've
got the the yam ISM forests and
therefore it's trees like to point that
one out and that's a fact with this
what's just been spoken all I got was a
humming noise I would rather have it in
black and white so I can partake in in
looking at it correctly I know I'm
requesting that to be pleased Thank You
councillor eaves Stanley's father has
happened here this evening if I heard
right in what has been proposed in the
meeting the first sentence it is
proposed that we set up a working party
what did my amendment say we set up a
working party all it is is that the
amendment has been put forward as had a
little bit more time to pack it out it's
already typed out it's ready there so
how we can actually say no and then say
yes now this is turning it into a
political issue and this is actually
something that I think is disgraceful
this is something that should be
cross-party if anyone suggested earlier
on I don't care what party that we put a
working party together even if that
motion came together with our reports
that came to us I think it would give us
much more cause to be unified on it
instead you've chosen to split the
chamber on this on a ridiculous
technicality and I am absolutely
astounded Castle McPherson Thank You
chairman
the crux of it is the new motion folks
out the original of the first one in the
fact that it will help it to be bespoke
and counselors family you yourself
mentioned bringing forward electric cars
is great but we need to know where that
electricity is coming from and by
passing it to the review who will
recreate a working group as you want to
me everyone's going to be happy
the fact that it's review they are
trained they do this they go through
working groups so it is best place there
I think Thank You chairman councilor mr.
Roy I I'm not going to be out of vote on
the motion so I still really can't take
in every single word of the motion I
believe it's going to review I think
it's working parties but because this
motion has been put without notice I do
not know what it says I cannot recall
word for word I cannot read it now and
ask coherent questions you might say
that I can't ask coherent questions
anyway though but I cannot because I
cannot see it it's not odd I would call
recycles it's an exempt well I want to
say it's fee honest but I cannot see how
this motion can be heard I would have to
abstain even though I voted for this
motion earlier which was councillor
Eve's amendment to the original motion
it sounds like a say motion I don't know
it is because I cannot read it and I
cannot recall something read to me a few
minutes ago word for Berkeley it's very
many words
he's poked out its pre-prepared one
earth the administration could not
accept cassadines motion when it sounds
very similar to the motion just put
forward I do not know but unfortunately
I'm going to have to abstain because I
do not know what the motion says word
for word counselor ft and we tried to
counsel these motion before I remember
correctly it was a motion its formal
working party to look at the report I
had a problem with the report is is so
pissed oak that is why I fight against
it is the difference does anybody else
wish to speak on this matter
no chair so yeah yeah I think on balance
we've not been given the opportunity to
read this and I'm finding it very hard
to comprehend what's in that motion and
it feels like I'm being asked to vote
with one arm tied behind my back so I'm
really gonna be forced into a position
to abstain on this which is a real shame
because it is a very important matter
and I would ask the chair again if we
can all be given a hard copy of this
motion thank you thank you can do forgot
that's already been voted on I'm afraid
cancer Williams did you want to come
back thank you
this is very important piece of
legislation that we need to take forward
thank you very much okay
I can't little quite Thank You chairman
I've been sitting and back and watching
the proceedings around what's been
taking place over the last few minutes I
do share counsel ease concerns about how
this has worked out this evening and if
this is an example of how this council
goes about cooperating across chamber
with all members then I do not have much
faith that working party set up in the
review committee is necessarily gonna be
anything better than what's taken place
so far despite the fact that I do have
confidence in the gym the review
- were to share that that committee it
it seems to be rather foolish process
that we've been through this evening
which was unnecessarily because there
was obviously opportunity as councilor
high head extended the opportunity for
the conservative group to to have an
involvement or amendment or coming up
with suggestions about this whole thing
from the beginning but it seems that
that was not accepted and decided to go
in their own way so I I have I have very
deep concerns as to how a working group
he's going to actually manage to perform
its task properly thinking it's a real
concern Thank You chairman very very
briefly I just want to pick up on the
couple of points that counselor a new
porter said that said I don't understand
what the difference between what
councilor Eve proposed and what counsel
limit is proposed I don't understand
what the differences are than the fact
that one's going to review that we it's
a working group as far as I'm concerned
I do respect the fact this is already
being voted on and please forgive my
naive see with this as well but we're
being asked to vote on something and I
don't understand what this resistance to
allowing us to physically see it I don't
understand the resistance their language
to have ten minutes of your time to
physically look at it and understand it
because all of us voted in favor of
councilor hoi's motion we all want this
to work every single one of us here want
this to work and if this is the right
thing for Rochford and the residents we
want this to work but I can't vote on
something I haven't read I can't vote on
something I haven't understood and I
respect the fact this has been voted on
but I would ask you again please allow
us ten minutes to read it and have a
hard copy so we can make an informed
decision
thank you gentlemen councillor Burton
Thank You chairman Truong keep it brief
and through you just in response I think
the main difference between the
amendment that was put forward by
councilor even the motion has been put
forward now is that the working group
will be within the review committee that
is precisely what the review committee
is there to do is to investigate and
come up with proposals for for council I
have no issue with it I won't
boating on it sir one of although the
review committee is there to scrutinize
work of the council not to come up with
policy for the council as far as I'm
aware we can't come up with
recommendations as well indeed council
Williams Thank You Joan if it will be
helpful I'm quite happy to read out the
emotion I think it would be helpful yes
thank you yes yes please I moved to
propose that the review committee be
asked to set up a cross-party working
group so as to I understand the
implications and recommend a policy to
this council on how I can reduce the its
carbon footprint and become carbon
neutral by 2030 at the latest to
consider and understand the costs and to
investigate external funding sources to
consider how this council can encourage
developers to design carbon neutral
homes and commercial premises through
the planning process to recommend a
policy for this council to consider by
April 2020 and to regularly update the
portfolio order for the environment upon
its work this council also calls upon a
majesty's government to explore
supporting domestic implementation of
sustainable development goals through
funding partnership roles within local
authorities to encourage the parishes to
work with RDC to achieve carbon
neutrality Thank You counsel Williams um
the motion has been proposed and
seconded I will now take a vote on on
that motion first a call for a recorded
vote please
sorry little bit too late right there
will be a recorded vote thank you
councillor Burton
pants and mrs. butcher
councilor canal
counselor mr. Carter
cancel mrs. Carter
can't still cut more
Hansol to dry for councillor FD
counselor leaves
councilor hook way counselor mrs. hoi
answer mr. hoi Khanh Seleucus girl
answer mrs lammle and so mrs. Macpherson
counselor Merrick counselor my own and
some Newport counselor mrs. Pavlin
can't see mrs. Rowe
Hansa mrs. Shaw answer mr. Shaw cancer
Smith
cancer sparing as the Stanley as this
step to answer award
instead web
hence the Wilkinson cancer Williams and
so Wilson cancer Wharton
remember see a motion has been passed 21
for and 11
abstentions thank you members will now
take item 12 on your gender purchase of
mechanical sweeper Council Williams is
to introduce this reform thank you
I'm thinking I heard you Counsell
Williams Thank You chairman I refer
members to consider the report of the
Assistant Director place of the
environment requesting the drawdown of
funds from earmark reserves to purchase
a mechanical sweeper suitable for
cleaning pavements this report request
to drawdown of 85,000 pounds from
reserves to allow the purchase of a
mechanical sweeper that is suitable for
cleaning pavements this will supplement
the existing fleet of sweepers which
could only access and clean the roads
that's aiding delivery of the contract
in line with the existing contractual
arrangement for the supply of interest
to service that contractor I therefore
would you want me to read out the
resolution yes please thank you I
therefore propose that as on page twelve
point three of the report Council
resolves one that's an addition to the
2019-20 capital program of 85 thousand
pounds to be approved for the purchase
of a mechanical suite map to the
drawdown of 85 thousand pounds from
earmark reserves be approved to finance
the purchase three that the authority be
delegated to the assistant director
place the environment in constant
consultation with the portfolio holder
for environment to reduce it suitable
mechanical sweeper I'm sure that their
own assistant director mr. Horton will
have answer any questions if there may
be Thank You Chancellor Thank You
councillor Williams counselor mr. Hoya
thank you and Kevin I've already asked
him mr. cotton a question on this and
I'm just asked it yeah because I think
it's quite important to be honest here
and I can either refer to you answer I
saved or we started answer I've received
because the question he's not just
mawkish nothing other members of the
opposition at least at all so I thought
this question as well because this
refers to purchase and we were wondering
why the option to lease a vehicle
particularly with a contract which will
be ending in the fairly short term
wasn't been seen being looked at as an
option here
I'm happy for because I think leasing if
the if the cost is the same or less
leasing to me off offers a better
opportunity than purchase we're not
lumbered with the vehicle we can give it
back after three years or seven years or
however long the leases for it's not
house
it is remains at least companies I
understand there could be issues around
repairs I'm sure that could be worked
out the I'm happy to give the answer
Cass Lawton gave me on happy for council
hotend give the answer
nothing is probably more appropriate for
mr. Hatem give the art sir thank you I
shall ask mr. Holden to give us the
answer
Thank You art Rami briefing the mmm
perhaps in the answer go I mean the key
wording in the recommendation is to
procure and so it's not necessary to to
purchase so that could either mean lease
or purchase so I haven't ruled out
leasing at this stage but I you know
that's something I need to sit down
discuss in detail series but you know it
will come down to the individual vehicle
that's chosen and whether there's even a
lease arrangement on offer for that so I
couldn't regains that kind of detail on
the reports because at the moment I'm
not clear I completely and what we're
going to purchase and there is a range
of vehicles we could consider so I'm not
sure what offers they will be on though
so some may have lease arrangements so
may not often this lease but we may
decide that still the best vehicle to
produce or the purchase of course on
that base it would it be appropriate
first to change the wording in 10.11 and
10.12 from purchase to procure cause to
me purchase means purchase procure as
mr. Halton says could mean police or
purchase first purchased to me means
purchase of appeals would that be
acceptable into this counsel
Marcus you are you okay with that yeah
okay
cows are Stanley Thank You chairman
before the procurement actually happens
will the officer find out what the
carbon footprint of that particular
vehicle or vehicles that is going to be
ascertained thank you I just can't get
on the short answer is yes anybody else
wish to speak on this matter no right
there's a recommendation the
recommendations the words in
recommendation word purchase be
substituted for procures they're all
agreed sorry chairman if I may just for
clarity purposes the new wording for
recommendation one is that's an
additional to the 2019-20 capsule
program of 85,000 be approved for the
procurement of a moment of a mechanical
sweeper number two is that the drawdown
of 85,000 from earmarks reserve be
approved to finance the procurement and
number three remains the same as that
authority be delegated to assistant
director a place environment in
consultation with the port folder for
environment to procure a suitable
mechanical sweeper is that all agreed
members thank you very much right
agenda item 13 River Crouch coastal
community team this will be introduced
by a mrs. hatching strategic director
Thank You chairman members the report is
self-explanatory the existing coastal
community team is currently run and
maintained primarily by more than
District Council who have resigned their
Secretariat and asked us to take it over
having spoken to the chairman of the
coastal community team it's felt that
there is still a significant amount of
mileage in the team not with certainly
at least the current round of coastal
communities funding which is just over
nine hundred and twenty four thousand
pounds which is being led by Essex
County Council and which will see some
investment in this part of the county so
the the recommendation is that we take
over the Secretariat and the small
amount of funding which currently
remains from the last round of funding
and it places us in a sound position to
take the coastal community team forward
and to propose to assist in the path to
prosperity project and to put it in a
good place for additional funding
streams in the future as we anticipate
that they will come from MH CLG if if
the if the recommendation isn't accepted
the alternative is that the team will be
dissolved and the responsibility will
pass to a coastal community team with
responsibility for the black water Thank
You councillor mr. Hawley thank you and
obviously I've declared an interest in
this I do sit on it as a member of the
public eye I was interested to read
forth contact with just four sodium's
areia Andrew Hutchins about this in
issue and I've also contacted Paulette
Chapman about it as well and copied
councillor mrs lammle in as well as
she's a representative on there my
concern was around the the council
representatives on the Crouch coastal
community team if you read the the set
up of it
more than because they were the
Secretariat and other word I remember it
they had four council representatives on
this team Rochford had one and chums had
one I had concerns that report didn't
mention that breakdown of membership
because I felt that he fraught sure
became the Secretariat it would be
inappropriate for Morden to retain for
members and ruptured only one under
sustained from Paulette Chapman M I'm
not sure if introductions was very the
controversial copy didn't or not or if
council mrs lammle was was copying but
don't actually agrees that perhaps it
might end up that Rochford has one
chance it has one member and Mauldin has
one member which to me would seem
appropriate because obviously sometimes
these things are going to get council
heavy sometimes or counselor heavy I
just want if there's any clarity around
that Thank You councillor mrs lammle
german if it helps every member of the
coastal community team as it has been
set up was actually sent an email from
the managing director Dean border who
who is managing director of the port
quick see who is the chairman of of the
existing group and I vice-chair that
group and we were all sent
and 4th of June explaining that this
would give the opportunity for the team
to review its focus going forward its
role and its membership and that is
exactly what we will be doing thank you
thank you sure yes just to confirm that
the body that has responsibility for its
composition is of course the coastal
community team itself in consultation
with our deem border the expectation is
that there will be an egm of the
existing membership and which the new
roles and responsibilities will be cast
new terms of reference agreed and we
will take the the the team forward
cancel mrs. Howe when it I mean
basically Malden spent all the money
that's way so I just I just want clarity
that we will get three members on the
coastal community otherwise I can't I'm
sorry I can't support me thank you as
I've just explained the only group that
can make a determination about the
composition of its membership is the
group itself and so the coastal
community team as was set up originally
as part of the what was then d CLG
funding is as its current composition as
the Secretariat is as this count if this
council approves the transfer of the
Secretariat and for this council has
become the accountable body for the
remaining funding and any future funding
going forward then that's what will
prompt the extraordinary general meeting
of the team and the roles and
responsibilities to be revoke revised at
that point there is clear expectation
from from myself from mrs. Romney and
from Dean border that that will change
to reflect the role of Rochford
as the accountable body
Thank You councillor Burton Thank You
chairman um I'm not sure if my original
question might hardly been answered by
councillor mrs. Roy what is the reason
for Morden resigning from this position
and what would be the consequences if we
don't take on that position Moulton runs
the coastal community team for the river
crouch and a separate coastal community
team for the Blackwater four reasons to
do with their internal reorganization
they were able to unable to continue to
support the crouch our coastal community
team and they offered us the opportunity
to take that forward if we don't take
that forward then the team will be
dissolved and the remaining
responsibilities of the team under the
previous funding and the remainder of
the of the budget will pass through the
Blackwater coastal community team yes
you are confident that the offer of us
taking on this position is a genuine one
can also wilkinson Thank You chef just
one quick question from what you were
just saying excuse me what are the
financial implications as a council for
us taking this one you may have already
covered apologize if I've missed that
but so what are the financial coats are
do we have to start paying out more
money thank you
there is no currently no financial
implications for the council there is a
small approximately 1,500 pounds that
remains from the from the previous fund
so we all have oversight responsibility
for the that expenditure the grant
funding comes in round successive rounds
from MHC LG the last round is the path
to prosperity which was awarded to Essex
County Council's we are we will be a
stakeholder in that bigger project and
ensure that part of that funding deals
with the the coastal path in our
district without the coastal community
team for the crouch well we simply won't
have that voice in terms of future
rounds of funding the MH seulji is
likely to open up additional rounding
funds in the future only those
organizations who are part of a coastal
community team will have a coastal
community will be eligible
apply for that future funding so
essentially we will rule ourselves out
of being able to apply for additional
funds does anybody else wish to speak on
this item no no but we have one
recommendation in members that set out
on page thirteen point three of the
report paragraph 8.1 and is that agreed
Thank You members may be noted I was
stained on that piece Jim Wright will
take item 14 then members Essex
countrywide travel unit governance
agreement and this will be introduced by
councillor Webb Thank You chairman Essex
counter travelers unit is hosted at
Essex County Council and managed by
joint committee with members from local
authorities across the county including
watcher District Council dealing with
unauthorized travel encampments is
resource intensive for local authorities
Essex County our travel unit provides
additional resources which enable timely
action to be taken by people with the
right expertise in addition Essex count
or travel unit works engaging engaging
with a gypsy traveller communities
addressing education health and social
care needs which would help reduce the
risk of unauthorized activities and help
deliver a better or develop a better
understanding between traveling from
settle communities it is now proposed to
renew the original joint committee
agreement for a further three years at
the cost of eight thousand two hundred
and twenty nine pounds per annum from
1920 which I thought is excellent money
for money and only a small increase in
fees from the eight thousand one hundred
and forty nine pounds per annum that we
currently paid I would ask members to
support the recommendation in 10.1 that
the council resolves to accept that
their management arrangement for that
for the Essex County boy travel unit be
accepted and that the essex county wide
traveler committee agreement 2019 which
will run for three years
thank you Thank You councillor Webb any
questions count the Hook way Thank You
chairman can I ask council Webb I
understand it that parish councils are
covered by this agreement but would it
would it be possible for parishes to be
able to have a copy a signed copy of the
agreement upon request if they only mind
that they are covered by by the
agreement thank you
Thank You councillor but that is my
understanding as well I will check that
with officers and then ask for to be
sent to you council mr. Hoya Thank You
chairman I know term there's a reference
to resolution of existing ones under
process serving on behalf of planning
authorities ie in relation to an
authorized developments the bullet
points from three point five on page
fourteen point one carrying over to
fourteen point two the final to our
management of local authority sites
unauthorized encampments and
unauthorized developments and that's why
I refer to the first bidder I said about
obviously one of the issues coming up in
planning at the moment is that we are
unable to defend unauthorized
developments or unauthorized sites
because we do not yet have a local town
with it with a site for a local
authority site if you like or an
authorised site within the local plain
will this make any difference where they
give us an ability to defend those sites
or not Ori still well we still like just
have to pass these because they are very
likely to be passed it an inspector by
an inspector because we do not have a
local site thank you
mr. Haddon will respond to that question
so the man is erect some confusion as to
who wants to answer this question I mean
I think the the key the key point for
members to note is the Essex County Road
traveler unit I mean it deals with a
whole number of issues relating to
travelers and it's about education
policy and Health and Safety on sites
and so on but I mean I think the key
issue is about unauthorized encampments
I think the issue related to
unauthorized development is a slightly
different issue and not really within
the remit of the of the traveler unit
the key issue for the traveler unit is
about unauthorized encampments though it
does clearly work closely on in terms of
providing education and help and advice
in relation to authorized developments
and where it's appropriate we'll provide
advice to travelers on unauthorized
developments but it's the decisions
about the planning aspects related to
unauthorized developments or the local
planning authority to deal with them
it's a bit of a subtle distinction but I
just come back was three point six does
refers specifically to new unauthorised
developments that was all thank you for
the clarification Thank You councillor
Stanley Thank You chairman I do
recognize that this organization is very
very useful in particular in to where
we've had encampments in north and using
their knowledge and and their
cooperation with with the travelers he's
most valuable and I think that's a value
for money so I approve that thank you
anybody else wish to speak on this item
no right we have one recommendation in
members on page fourteen point three of
the report paragraph 10.1 is that agreed
Thank You members right that been the
last item on the agenda I closed a
meeting at 9:00 8:54 Thank You Mavis
cough members to be upstanding for the
Chairman that looks slightly slow
what
Thanks
[Laughter]
[Music]